the images are almost unbearably
distressing collapsed buildings which
are the main reason for the catastrophic
loss of life resulting from this
earthquake so why was this one so bad
well the main thing of course was just
how severe the earthquake was this is a
shake map for the first 7.8 magnitude
Quake the red triangles are part of a
sensor Network that measure ground
movement in some locations the speed the
ground mood was extreme here in hajila
ground acceleration for the Quake was
approaching 8 meters per second in curry
Khan was well above seven meters a
second now these measurements are
preliminary but Sky News understands
that in some areas they exceeded levels
expected in turkey's earthquake design
codes buildings are designed to cope
with a one in 475-year earthquake event
and not collapse in a one in two and a
half thousand year event yet the shaking
appears to exceed the upper limit of
what would be expected every two and a
half thousand years
even a very well uh designs and well
executors building would have suffered
would have would have been challenged uh
but again this doesn't rule out that the
building stock that's that we are um
seeing uh basically uh collapsing uh was
free of uh defects and problems
previous earthquakes in Turkey have
highlighted those problems both the age
but also quality of newer building
construction the city of gaziantet
experienced considering less intense
shaking yet buildings still failed
sometimes catastrophically and these
risks were known last year a team of
Turkish seismologists studied the city
of gaziantep using earthquake risk data
they identified which neighborhoods were
most vulnerable to a big Quake those in
the darkest colors in this map were they
forecast 50 to 60 percent of the
buildings to suffer damage generally the
areas with the oldest or poorest quality
buildings but crucially the hypothetical
earthquake they based their study on was
10 times less powerful than the one that
struck on Monday
so age and quality of buildings was a
major factor but so too perhaps was the
estimation of risks and don't forget
this wasn't just one earthquake a huge
magnitude 7.5 Aftershock toppled
buildings that survived the initial
quake and damaged others Beyond repair
even these structures that remain
standing may now be uninhabitable a
colossal challenge for authorities
already dealing with at least tens of
thousands of people made homeless by
this disaster